[Music]
it's a landlord hey Devon yeah you doing
Bob are you doing yeah just stopping by
just wanted to check up on everything
okay nope
closet look good door is strong so y'all
settling me yeah
we've been living here a year and a half
so we have so how these cupboards
working out for you nobody in here
besides those stuff which looks good
thank you
completely unrelated have y'all seen a
four foot eleven dude with a purple
beard up in here no no no no one's in
here probably because we locked the door
oh you got the body like a rat J you can
just squeeze through the vents yeah so
you think somebody's hiding in my
apartment no I told you it's just a
social call
I mean why would Jo be in here anyway
Gerald there is a man with a purple
beard named Gerald in my apartment he'll
know why did you see him about four foot
nine got a purple beard Oh by-the-by
have you seen a full foot five trouble
beard baby Devon what's going on okay
you know I'm gonna level with y'all
there was a full foot three with a
purple beard named Gerald he's somewhere
in this building why does he keep
getting smaller every time you mention
him seriously cuz I didn't want to along
y'all he is disturbingly small really
you good guy he's
righto I mean here do anything to get
money for crack anything okay I mean I
get it he will murder you
well we certainly hope you find him oh
I'm old phantom don't worry about that
cuz I'm gonna look low and then stop the
Inca penis y'all
you